thibault vous êtes en premier l'objet
indispensable de la semaine c'est quoi
vous savez j'adore les belges adorent
les animaux
voyez c'est l'objet indispensable tout
simplement concerne un animal qui me
touche profondément
le rat et pour cette rentrée ce jeudi
attestée ramon oui moi je suis rentré au
ya rien qui va rentrer dans l'espace
sachez que ça va vous faire quand même
temps il yad'autres gynéco qui s'est
endormi jack ça va faire non pas du tout
regardez une trousse une croix qu'est ce
que j'ai vu une image choquante c'est
quoi il a parlé de quoi pour que je le
fais pour 40 $ au curé vous une houle a
parlé quel animal de quel animal par
l'étude il apparaît maintenant de cannes
c'est la porte aux nues il en a pas oui
moi aussi alors je ferme les yeux
10le l'éléphant non par les durs à
battre